at the end of Loki episode 4 it seems
like everything is about to explode and
everybody is about to die however we
know that this is not going to be the
case because we have two episodes left
in our last video we covered how Loki
and Sylvie are probably going to use the
tin pad of he who remains to go back in
time and try again we've had a few
different TV spots and trailers for Loki
season 2 show us Loki say all right
let's try to do this again basically
telling us that yes they are going to go
back in time and try to get it right and
it seems like they're going to do this
more than once but the question is what
exactly is going to happen when they get
it right well if you've been following
the channel we still believe that he who
remains is orchestrating this entire
thing that everything including Victor
timley being spaghettified at the end of
episode 4 and Loki then having to go
back in time in episode five and six
which I think we'll see is a part of he
who remains as plan and OB is most
likely working with him hate to say it
but OB could be working with the villain
and like we mentioned in our last video
I do believe that there is a scene in
episode 4 where he was possibly lying to
everybody so in this video we're going
to dive into episode 4 and break down
why we think he who remains is
orchestrating the entire thing and why
OB could be working with he who remains
trying to help him return and if you're
new be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest breakdowns
or MCU news and we're doing a giveaway
right now if you subscribe and leave a
comment you're automatically entered for
a chance to win a PS5 an Xbox series X
some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner gets to pick one item
and we pick one winner at the end of
each month so before Loki season 2 even
started we've had a few insiders out
there tell us that he who remains is
going to return and kind of be like a he
who returns in fact today The Insider
can we get some toast tweeted this the
writing of Loki season 2 continues to
impress the theme of this season seems
to be how cyclical stories and even time
can be from Obi and Victor cementing the
orboros nature of their relationship by
meeting each other to Loki realizing
that he pruned himself in the future
everything's working in a circle almost
as if it's all being orchestrated by
someone who will return it all comes
back around and just like OB said in
episode 4 it's a snake eating its own
tail in which can we get some toast
posted a picture of which of course is
called an or borus now this is what
we've been thinking since episode 1
because in the Loki season 1 finale he
who remains said that he orchestrated
everything everything leading up to
where Loki and Sylvie met he who remains
at the end of time in the Citadel he
made happen so that's literally
everything he had it all written down he
showed it to them from Loki and Sylvie
falling in love with each other to them
killing the fake timekeepers to arriving
at the end of time making the TVA a mess
that was all a part of his plan and then
at the end when he was about to die he
told Sylvie see you soon now at the time
we thought he was referring to his
variance but what if he wasn't what if
this is indeed all a part of his plan
and he is going to return we talked
about in a previous video how in the
comics Kang actually has the ability to
transfer his Consciousness into another
variant before he dies we believe that
this could be what he is doing or what
he has already done before he died in
the finale of season 1 when he was
speaking to Loki and
the timeline had already started to
Branch out which mean there began to be
other variants of him in these other
timelines so when he died right before
he could have transferred his
Consciousness and this person this
variant could be trying to return and
this could be who the Insiders are
referring to as he who returns however
there's kind of a problem the TVA might
explode but that's where we believe his
good old buddy orboros could come into
play we know that OB created the TVA
handbook we know that he was with he who
remains since the very beginning that's
a very long time to know somebody and
you most likely wouldn't betray somebody
that you created something so cosmically
huge to TVA that literally controls the
Multiverse OB created that with he who
remains and for eons OB has been a part
of it so why would OB betray he who
remains I really don't think he would
and there is also a very particular
scene in episode 4 that could be hinting
at OB and Victor timley slhe who remains
Kang working together when Obi and
Victor timley are talking about
integrating the device that Victor
created into obes device he states that
it would take a long time and then
victor goes up to him and says if anyone
can do it it's you and me and then they
shake hands but the camera makes sure to
focus on the two of them shaking hands I
think this is foreshadowing I think that
they're trying to hint at the two of
them working together now it may may not
be this exact variant Victor timley
working with ob but I think they're
hinting at a variant of Kang of he who
remains and OB working together here
with this scene I think this scene right
here is very intentional so again why
would OB betray somebody that he created
the TVA with I don't think he would and
I think this is actually shown possibly
in episode 4 because like I mentioned I
think Obie lied in the season finale of
episode 1 it's very clear that he who
remains created the vaa not Victor
timely and in fact he who remains
confirms that he existed in the 31st
Century not in the 19th century he
existed way in the future from where we
are at now that's why he had the
technology to create everything and
become king the Conqueror Victor timley
did not have that technology and in fact
Ora Boris even says that when he meets
Victor timley and doesn't know he's
Victor timley right away he says I
learned everything I know from a 19th
century inventor named Victor timley if
he had the resources he would have been
bigger than Einstein I think that this
line is either one A Lie by OB that is
very intentional or two a lie that he
doesn't necessarily know that he is
sayane let me explain like I mentioned
we know that he who remains created the
TVA and we know that he was not a
variant of Victor timely as he explained
he was Nathaniel Richards which is King
the conqueror's original name he existed
in the 31st Century he built the TVA and
he won the multiversal war this was also
confirmed in episode 4 we saw the past
of Rana RN Slayer and he who remains and
we found out that she led his army in
the multiversal war fight so he had the
TVA and everything set up before he
actually won the war but point being
this was Nathaniel Richards from the
31st Century who created the TVA not
Victor timely from the 1900s so why is
OB telling Victor that he learned
everything from a 19th century scholar
well one he could simply be lying it's
clear that he who remains needs the TVA
to not explode in the time to be fixed
to be able to handle more timelines so
clearly he has a plan in place for that
to happen and it has to involve OB and
possibly even Victor timely as well
because we know that Victor adds his
device that basically fixes the problem
that OB had this could be why he who
remains told Miss minutes and raana Rin
Slayer to give this variant of him that
existed in the 1900s the TVA guide book
so he could go on to create this one
very specific invention that could
complete ob's technology to fix the time
Loom OB might know this because he could
be in on he who remains his plan and
could simply be going along with it
going along with whatever the plan is to
try and get he who remains to return if
he's a part of the plan this makes sense
it makes sense he would lie and
essentially just do whatever as long as
that time Loom gets fixed it doesn't
matter what he says or option two is
that his memory was erased with
everybody else's and he who remains
actually kind of put Victor timely into
his life as a part of he who remains his
plan again for whatever reason that we
don't know yet he who remains clear
clearly needs the time Loom to be able
to handle more timelines and the TVA
can't explode otherwise he can't go to a
TVA he built the TVA he obviously
doesn't want it to explode plus he needs
it to control everything so he who
remains could have simply planted Victor
timley into Ora boris's life what's
interesting is we don't actually know
how Victor timely taught Ora Boris
remember the TVA was created in the 31st
Century at least maybe even after that
so how did OB somebody who was working
with the TVA in the 30 first century get
influenced by a 19th century inventor
while he who remains kind of putting
that information inside of him after
erasing his memory makes sense because
somebody from the future learning from
somebody in the past about how to create
something as complicated as the TVA that
doesn't make sense now I've heard some
people talk about Ora Boris and say that
he could be a variant of he who remains
himself and while I do like this Theory
I don't think it's true because then
they wouldn't need Victor timley for for
his temporal Aura in theory if OB is a
variant of he who remains then his
temporal Aura should work to get into
the system of the TVA but it doesn't
then again at the same time he did not
stick his head into the device that Obie
made but again this still could be kind
of a trick by OB and he who remains now
of course there is always the
possibility that Victor timley could be
faking everything and he really could
just be he who remains pretending to be
a variant this Victor timely fellow and
yes he does die at the end of episode 4
but we know they're going to go back in
time and keep trying until they fix it
we've also seen a scene in the promos
where Loki is the one who walks out onto
the bridge going towards the time Loom
just simply as he is no sudon whatsoever
now he's a God so perhaps he can survive
that temporal energy but in that scene
it doesn't look like Victor timley is
the one that goes out so there is a
scenario most likely where Victor timley
lives so he might become he who remains
in which that scene where he has shaking
hands with with ob could be quite
literal him and OB are indeed working
together and that could be a part of he
who remains his plan before he died he
could have simply informed them or told
Miss menance to inform both of them
however I think Victor timley is gone
and I think he who remains was simply
using him to give OB the technology that
he needed to fix the time Loom and save
the TVA and as Miss minut said before
she got shut down Victor timely will
never be him but this is just our Theory
let us know what you think about this in
the comments down below and if you have
a theory of your own let us know don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
stay up to date on all the latest
breakdowns you can find us on Instagram
and Twitter as well and as always thank
you all so much for watching woof
woof